let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
welcome back to the show thanks for
joining us through the break
we have our regular guest
dakota von adams
are our our regular white nationalist
uh
expert as it were he's not awesome
you know
right well we're going to talk about
the word white nationalist uh later on
in the interview uh when it comes to
stuart giving a
a jailhouse interview to a none other
than the gateway pundit
which is another story in and of itself
but you you have become on the show the
oath keepers proud boys and white
nationalist groups and a really militia
expert here for us at the tony michaels
podcast i didn't mean to pause so long
dakota yeah i'm just uh coming at you
live
from the podcast shed
great great yeah what you you're you're
you're streaming now you're doing some
of your own content so that's great so
we'll we'll do a shameless plug later on
so everyone stick around through this
interview that way you know where to
find
kill my sub stack yeah exactly exactly
you can you can pimp your pimp your
content here on the on the show so let
me start because i know
as soon as the hearing was over just i
think it was about an hour afterwards
you messaged me said hey i have a lot to
say
um
so let's start with the hearing the the
the last hearing that we saw which is
number eight
in in the season one finale as it were
what's the dog's name by the way
this is mocha she's very big
okay yeah well the audience loves the
the animals the audience loves animals
so um
maybe mocha will help us do this hearing
uh talk back and forth so what did you
make of the hearing what things stood
out to you the most because i know
you were talking earlier about the
some people were making comments about
it but you had a certain thought about
it what
what was your take from the la the last
hearings the season finale as it were my
take from the season finale is it
definitely feels like a pre-planned
produced season finale this feels like
when like i've said before when you are
writing an essay
where you're trying to get a point
across the general public you start out
by telling them what you're going to
tell them you tell them and then you
tell them what you told them this
episode the eighth session
was the summary episode it's the one
that is the penultimate edited together
concise one-stop timeline
for you to show your relatives and
friends and associates who might have
absorbed all the lies about the january
6 insurrection
definitively with video evidence
and
direct visual aids
uh discrediting all of that and showing
the truth this is where they throw in
all the meme footage which is very very
smart they get josh hawley skadoodling
for his life they get
uh trump's bloopers and outtakes
they get discovery channel special mode
where we get the 3d model of the white
house to demonstrate exactly how short
the walk would have been for trump to go
to his briefing room and talk the mob
down
at any time juxtaposed with
edited in on the little 3d rendered tv
screen in the oval in the uh not the
oval office the presidential dining room
the live fox news covers that he would
have been watching at that exact moment
and
showing that simultaneously with
uh
testimony of secret service members
relaying last messages to their families
because they thought they were about to
die
in combat with the january 6-inch
insurrectionist to try to protect mike
pence from a lynch mob
that
all put together
with kinzinger on fire with
cheney going after bill barr
with
the pro-trump
uh
extraordinarily trumpy uh witnesses who
were proud of their work with his
administration
uh who turned on him because of january
6th
this is the
pulling the wolf from your one kind of
smart uncle's eyes episode that's what
it's for and i think it does an
excellent job of that so for people who
already know all of it
and this is all old familiar ground it's
not going to add a lot new
for showing clips
or showing a single episode that is
highly entertaining
and well edited so it keeps your
interest
to somebody that you know who might be
reached
or has absorbed wrong information but
isn't clinging to it as part of its
identity this is it this is this is
the weapon that's been handed to you by
the january 6 committee
why i can't agree with you more on that
on that point but and a couple things
too that i'd like to add now the the
the story where they're telling
from the dining room when uh kevin
mccarthy actually was able to get on the
phone with donald trump the president
united states at that time and his first
instinct his first instinct dakota which
i almost thought of you immediately is
when the president united states like oh
it's antifa right that's that was the
first instinct that donald trump had to
blame
blame the entire thing on antifa it was
it was almost like he was a pepe the
frog internet troll right in my thread
like oh antifa and and but kevin
mccarthy said no no they're maki my
staff is running away and they're your
supporters they're the ones that were
down there listening to you and then he
said and they he immediately immediately
in this thread that we are listening to
right he immediately changes his mind
that this is no longer antifa it is his
supporters you are correct mr mccarthy
but you must not love your country and
you must not love me as much as they do
that's the problem like it
he totally [ __ ] him on the antifa
narrative and then he completely does a
180 and then says well here's the reason
why i i don't know that moment in and of
itself really kind of describes
not just the mindset
of trump himself but it really does show
that the tail is wagging the dog right
like that is his
that trump didn't invent that response
that everything's antifa
he is he's seen this response and he's a
copycat right don't you think
yep and it uh all it did was confuse the
messaging where they could have stuck to
one consistent narrative it was all
antifa
and burned everybody who was on the
ground and then pretended everything was
fake or they could have stuck with these
were patriots this was a legitimate
action to protest a stolen election
which is becoming a standard gop party
line and ashley babbitt was a martyr
but they tried to do both because of
confused messaging
from
trump's insiders that started
immediately as they tried to grapple
internet trends and go with what was
most popular and while that worked out
pretty well in the past it
in this case
muddied and confused
their narrative and i think it's hurt
them more than it's helped
i think you're right the other the other
significant thing
um with the witnesses because you
brought up the witnesses we we saw a
former national security council advisor
a lifelong republican he even tried even
tried during his testimony to to kind of
it was kind of gross right he
it was
disgusting
to make trump into this great presidency
right it was real it really was [ __ ]
vile
that the witness was doing that but i
think it was important to show that this
is not some [ __ ] left-wing
[ __ ] right that's not what this that's
not who he was he was a trumper and but
even he was so disgusted that day
watching dereliction of duty and donald
trump doing nothing so that way he could
actually become the king of the united
states or maga whatever the hell he
actually whatever his aim was here i
think that's the actual thing we didn't
get is what his name was but i don't
know if we'll ever know that you know
short-sighted grasp on power i can give
you my personal theory which is
constructed almost entirely from
certain similarities and psychological
profile between uh my father stuart
rhodes and donald trump because they're
both malignant narcissists
when stewart
founded oath keepers from that point on
his future was set because once he had a
taste of being the old keeper's militia
general and the attention
and the respect from uh men who were a
lot better at him in a lot of a lot
better than him in a lot of ways
objectively
and the money and the little amount of
work that he could do in the
adoration uh
he could never ever go back to
regular life after that he could never
go back to work even working as a lawyer
and flubbing his way through the work
day doing jackal or
working for a political activist group
from then on
only the level of adoration that being a
militia general and savior of america
would get him
would be enough and only the easy
lifestyle that that brought him would be
enough
i
subscribed to the theory that trump
didn't really intend to win the election
and now that it was inner circle that he
was going to parlay it into
his own media channel and rule
right-wing talk forever
off of the
off of the energy of the election was
stolen from me and make that the new
birther conspiracy for the entire
clinton presidency i believe that was
plan a that's pretty well known at this
point a lot of people think that
once he was in
trump's ability to be anything but the
president was ruined because that he was
addicted within the first hit
of presidential respect and power
and he
regardless even of
the fact that he
was likely headed to prison if he lost
power
he was psychologically incapable of
giving up powers an authoritarian
personality they don't relinquish
control once they have it he could never
again step back down to a position of
any less importance than the president
which is why he has maintained remained
effectively present in his own mind
and
is insisting on the stolen election
and playing to his crowd all through the
united states i think presently
the plan as it is has been to run a
weird quantum
will he won't he political campaign
that
as a side benefit screws over all of his
rivals within the republican party who
could one day steal his mojo and to burn
the gop for failing to be 100 behind him
during the election fraud and the coup
attempt
and also i believe just to grift money
so that he can flee the country that's
probably the conscious plan but
subconsciously
trump is never going to be able to
accept
losing
and
just leave quietly to be putin's pet
president in exile which is one of the
possibilities that i was thinking about
in january of 2020
he's not going to be able to do it he's
going to be compelled within himself to
try again because he will never be able
to let go
of the idea of him as the most important
special man in the world
i think you're right because he does he
does have this complex right and it is
that it is that authoritarian complex
but more than anything is this selfish
need to uh advance his ego right
now
you know speaking of of the witnesses
matthew pottinger as we uh referred to
him before there was also
sarah matthews she was the former deputy
white house uh press secretary a very
young lady this almost kind of this the
same story that we
see working her way up through the
administration is cassidy hutchinson
now cassidy hutchinson was in the chief
of staff's office now sarah matthews in
the press secretary's office but what
i've found
um
really telling one of the moments where
she's describing
trying to get through these people's
skulls of how
gross it was for them to be doing
nothing and watching as our democracy
was trying to be overtaken by these this
band of maga idiots right was under
attack by a cult of physical attack by a
kind of personality who would accept
nothing but their dear leader right and
and and for no reason other than he is
their leader
and and the moment where she's
describing
if we can't we can't have him admit
because we don't want to look like we're
losing we don't want to lose the
narrative and she she she thrust her
hand up towards the tv she says and she
says does it look like we're [ __ ]
winning like what what do you think this
looks like and really i think going back
to your first statements on the hearing
itself
i think that's the biggest challenge is
getting some of this stuff
in front of
some of these people who still either
don't know what happened on january 6
because i still think there's
you know not maybe not a large
percentage but there's a large number of
people and they vote in this country i
think it's a large percentage i think
it's the majority of my town at least
the majority of the guys that i run into
on construction sites or in local
emergency services even who genuinely
don't know what happened on the six and
they've simply absorbed
the
media presented to them by fox news and
newsmax
right whatever whatever that narrative
was it was a nothing burger right they
have no clue what actually happened um
but some of these bites these sound
bites can really work their way through
like you were saying uh some of the
previous hearings we saw the the ketchup
story where he was throwing ketchup
against the wall we saw the story about
the secret service having a scuffle
inside the the the presidential mark
motorcade which those two stories in and
of itself really don't speak to the the
crime of a coup
exactly they don't have a lot of bearing
um on
criminal evidence
except in like what they're related to
obviously trump trying to get the secret
service to take him to the capitol
is uh circumstantial evidence that he
was involved with the mob going up the
steps because he wanted to lead them
but much more importantly
throwing the burger and throwing the
ketchup and trying to choke a secret
service agent
um in wrestling back and forth over the
headrest in the presidential armored suv
that is
a memeable image
that will spread and become a running
joke it's the kind of messaging
that
democrats and liberals on the left have
been nearly incapable of
for decades
it's the kind of thing where like the
federalist is now is trying to attack
the january 6 committee for
uh
hiring tv producers from abc at all when
the reality is they're terrified
that the opposition has finally caught
on
to their method
absolutely well and we and we
we
witness this with the tape of the
outtakes like you brought up earlier
because we we knew there were outtakes
right and and some some folks and i even
thought that it was going to be outtakes
from the original message from the rose
garden where he says you know you're
good people i love you you know really
stroking stroking this whole
again the tail wagging the dog because
he can't go against his people because
he really truly has stuck to that
principle that i can't go against putin
and i can't go against my supporters
like if i if i start to do those two
things i'll lose control i'll lose power
and but in the statement the outtakes
that i thought were so significant and
everyone watched
were the outtakes from the statement of
january seventh and i think why it's so
significant is not exactly what he says
but him throwing a
him throwing a fit about what he refuses
to say right and then how he was marking
out these things he can't say that he
can't because
the tail won't wag me if i say those
things right they'll abandon me and
that's why he's stopped taking credit
for the vaccine entirely he
tested that out and crowd work at his
rallies
didn't play well and he dropped it
forever right right because because he
he knew that that was not something that
they would wag the tail or the tail
would wag the dog with they wouldn't
play that game right so it's always him
trying to get the tail to wag the dog
right that's all it is is because he's
always playing tonight and steve bannon
does this really well too um and you
know this with the deep dart you know
4chan 8-chan and how he's the pied piper
of these trolls out there and now donald
trump has four [ __ ] shirts and his
weeping skin lesions right becoming the
in-cell god
which i'm sure we'll get to steve bannon
here in a little bit when we get to the
part that the actual season finale
didn't show
um because we talked about this
beforehand off camera
the one thing that really didn't give us
the satisfaction
um we got a lot of satisfaction out of
the holly video which we'll talk about
here in a second but the thing we didn't
get satisfaction from and we thought we
might see
is the thing me and you have talked
about a lot and and
it exists we know it exists we know the
committee knows that exists and they
know the back channel that is there and
the back channel between stuart rhodes
and the actual orders for that qrf the
weapons that are were stored across the
potomac
and the present united states we did not
hear or
any kind of hint at all
of who and what that back channel was
the day of the fifth and the day of the
six
we we didn't get any kind of
satisfaction there so why do you think
that is
i think that's because uh
the january 6 committee and the
department of justice are working
towards overlapping but not quite
unanimous purposes the january 6
committee is racing the clock to get
the entire story presented in an
entertaining format with
clips and visual aids in front of the
american people before the elections so
that everyone understands what's at
stake ahead of the midterms
running under the gun
to put together everything that you and
i and probably a good portion of your
audience already knows in a concise
one-stop playlist
or broadcast that
everyone can look at to get fully caught
up or close to it the department of
justice is i believe approaching this
like a mob investigation working their
way up the chain building a bulletproof
case because if they swing at trump it
has to connect
and so we get the department of justice
in many cases running out ahead
of the publicly visible work the
department of justice is doing i mean
the committee running out ahead of the
department of justice
at least in their public work
and where we see a weird gap where we've
had the leaks before we know
that stewart was stewart and tario were
in the friends of stone group chat
is seen reporting that they have that
group chat
we
have heard the reports of stuart on the
phone with a mysterious intermediary
who might have been able to put him in
touch with trump but refused to on the
night of the six when it was clear that
the coup had not worked and was being
abandoned for now
and the committee didn't address that
the committee didn't even really address
oath keepers except for
the disgusting walkie-talkie
audio log intercepts and the reason for
that i think is because that is
something the department of justice is
pursuing heavily because if they have
hard evidence of those connections
the chain of command from trump to roger
stone michael flynn down to proud boys
and oath keepers for the paramilitary
operation happening under cover of the
mob
that is the smoking gun for bringing
trump and his inner circle up on serious
charges
and the notable absence of
any mention of it
in
the public hearings in season one
i think is an indicator that that's
being pursued very aggressively and it's
being taken very seriously especially
now as we're seeing that the department
of justice has issued
a large number of grand jury subpoenas
related to the fake elector slates
they're
they're going after
the prongs
of this coup attempt and there is no way
that they're overlooking the
paramilitary operation especially with
the looming oath keepers and proud boys
seditious conspiracy trials
well i think um your your suggestion
that doj is moving towards an up the
ladder
to a bigger fish you know that's what
the um prosecutors use the language big
fish small fish and i think they're
getting bigger bigger fish in front of
the grand jury because we know mark's
there's reports that mark short who is
the vice president or former vice
president mike pence's chief of staff
who was with him in the parking garage
when they wouldn't go with secret
service i have different feelings on
that um now than i did before the
hearings but we can we can leave that
for another day i want to get back to
because you brought up the the radio
chatter because we're kind of talking
about the back channel and that radio
chatter between the oath keepers
so do i i mean
you were a round steward you were around
these militia groups your entire life
was it pretty common to have a back
channel in different um chains of
command or tell us about that this is
qrf tell us about how that would
actually work and what the protocol
would be
well the anything large scale happens in
the militia movement is
a weird fractious coalition of different
disparate groups and little factions
everybody's got a tiny fighter
and
what we're hearing there is
like it's strangely familiar to me the
way they're talking about is they have
their mission
their undergoing it there
um but they're keeping one eye on what
the president is saying publicly with
his tweets in case it means a mission
scrub that's why when he says uh don't
attack capitol police the one guy is
like oh he didn't say anything about not
attacking congress people
so so what do you mean what do you mean
by mission scrub describe describe what
that means
in in simple terms what if trump had
called it off publicly said everyone
stop
go home
and if they'd continue them attempting
their mission at that point they would
no longer have had the cover of the mob
to operate within it would have just
been them
and it it's the uh their mission which i
believe was
um abducting nancy pelosi or other
senators and seizing
the boxes with the electoral votes to
create a delay in the certification
process that could be exploited
that would not have been possible
without the coverage of thousands of
violent trump supporters
and trump could have called off those
thousands of supporters
in one broadcast or one tweet it
wouldn't have even taken walking to the
briefing room could have done it from
his phone anytime so they're seeing
these tweets pop up they're going yeah
he hasn't told everyone to back off yet
we're still a go and they're laughing
about it so
what you're saying so what you're
hearing in that in that radio chatter
is
that um
they're taking what trump is saying or
what more maybe more importantly what
he's not saying
as orders is that kind of what you're
saying yes
so yeah so so if
if let's let's just play out a scenario
here because we don't again we don't
know who that back channel was and if we
do know that stuart rhodes was maybe
desperate to contact the president
united states where did where did the
fallout happen you think in the timeline
in that 187 minutes when stewart and the
oath keepers had no idea what the
mission was anymore right they had no
idea what their orders were were we
still going forward where do you think
it fell apart uh for them was it when
the national guard shows up because mike
pence kind of forced the issue and
donald trump had to have the national
guard come in is that where you think it
was or where do you think it is in that
187 minutes i think
um it's whatever point it is where
the momentum stalls and they do not
get their hands
on the senders it's becoming clear that
they're not making any further progress
towards their strategic goals and
there's just
a mob milling about causing property
damage
in the capital it's when stewart is
getting repeated messages from the qrf
guy asking if they're going in
and he's saying not yet
it's that it's then it's this it's in
that span
in the slow moving uh grinding to a halt
of their momentum
when
the tide starts to turn
and they're no longer progressing
towards their goals and then you hear
that the national guard is coming and
then trump tells everybody and we love
you go home and it's like oh [ __ ] i
guess it's vietcong tunnels in kentucky
now
right so so it goes from in and maybe
and maybe the oath keeper's mind the
leadership to mine stewart's mind it
goes from hey we are going to actually
be able to do an insurrection here uh
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo coup which
i that's what i call it um it goes from
that to
him seeing it as oh well damn this is
just a riot now right that they're going
to call in they're going to call in the
riot police they're going to call the
ride off they're going to pull it off
and now it's just a riot we don't have
the cover anymore to actually commit an
insurrection rather it's to
um take the the actual
valid state electors and switch them
with the sh you know the ones that
that's the continuing the continuing
eastman memo plan which stewart was not
a pivotal player in
from anything that i've seen and that is
why i think we have that report of
stuart on the phone with his
intermediary
uh begging him to put trump on
and begging him to
influence trump to call up oath keepers
and militias
uh and deputize them
to
seize control of the capital and
reinstate him to the presidency and this
is kind of the martial law
the martial law insurrection act right
this is yeah stewart kind of has this in
his brain which is which is uh really
flooring from the stories that you've
told before about the oath keepers in
his mission because that's the actual
opposite of what yeah oath keepers
it's in the founding 10 orders we will
not obey is uh
martial law
and the suspension of the constitution
is never ever okay and always to be
opposed
and the complete 180 degree flip on that
is just a signal of
stewart placing his personal loyalty in
trump rather than his oath to the
constitution and that it was all a lie
and
but don't you think that this goes back
to that authoritarian power is that that
absolutely stewart was was terrified of
a bite administration of abiding doj and
you know he's he's paranoid still about
the bundy ranch and what happened there
and um i mean
some of that comes into play where it's
maybe not even as much about trump as it
is about stewart you think it absolutely
was just about stuart because his
um he clung to trump for his own safety
he clung to trump because clinging to
maga was the path of least resistance
for continued relevance of oath keepers
and for making money
it what and he
especially whenever he got plugged in
with that
intermediary it became an opportunity to
make oath keepers into something very
important
in the coming order
when trump would cement his control over
the united states
uh
placing do you think stuart rhodes had
i just want to play play a game here
real quick so you think oh harry rhodes
head like this fantasy that donald trump
becomes the king of the united states
the constitution is no more which means
trump can basically crown him the
general the uh
commander-in-chief as it were type thing
that you see in a lot of autocracies
because a lot of autocracies the king is
not actually the head of the the
military they're not the
commander-in-chief
they pass that on that's too much
[ __ ] work right a king wants to you
know do different things than than worry
about what the military do you think
that some some sick twisted
you know reality that stuart rhodes
thought that's what was going to happen
absolutely
absolutely i think he was gunning for
being the head of trump's internal
security division he wanted to be the
head of
trump's revolutionary guard or a
republican guard to pull from
contemporary examples
and if the coup had gone off
i would have been able to foresee an
eventual power struggle where stewart
would have attempted to oust
eric prince or michael flynn
uh whichever one ended up in charge of
trump's loyal military
um yeah okay this is the right-hand man
i i am i am regretting going down this
imaginary road already it's um we would
we would be in canada and i would be
forming a
a dark mirror of all the militia groups
on the uh the ones that watch the
southern border and patrol to catch to
catch drug mules and they're full of
nazis
i would have been forming my anti-oath
keepers uh militia border recon right
with this with the back with the backing
of uh
canadian intelligence services for
whenever they wanted people just shot
without having to arrest or turn them
over it sounds like you've been on trump
it sounds like you've been on secret
meetings with the uh canadian uh
intelligent forces so
but yeah but but here's the thing back
to
stuart rhodes and this back channel and
um why it is so important in that 187
minutes is because stewart rhodes
actually
um and rather it's because
this coup attempt was done by a bunch of
buffoons or not
stewart wasn't let in on the plan
obviously of what the actual plan was
because i actually don't think that
there was an one strategic actual plan i
think that's the other thing that the
earrings have shown us is that
trump was willing to do whatever it took
it didn't matter which avenue he didn't
care if the supreme court made him
president he didn't care if the if the
oath keepers and the proud boys and a
bunch of white nationalists went and
committed violence and made him
president they saved him saved him
or or if
whatever the case the state electors the
state legislators the courts the doj
whoever would just make him president
that's what he would have went with he
didn't give a [ __ ] it was it didn't he
didn't have one strategic plan it was
like we'll just throw spaghetti at the
wall and see how much
fractured chain of command and one thing
that i think is clearly demonstrated by
that audio log
of the walkie-talkie communications from
the oath keepers stack
that made entry and from the signal
chats and that we have
where uh stuart is talk is in
communication with his group and the qrf
is once
the day started going once january 6
went underway
um there was no direct communication
with stewart's handlers higher up the
chain
uh whoever he was reporting to that
brought him in on the overall plan they
did not have direct communication
probably for security reasons for the
only smart thing that they did
in the sense of avoiding criminal
prosecution
but it also undermines the chances of
their operation being successful because
now
when they're fully committed on the six
and when the stack and the proud boys
are leaving the crowd early to show up
at the capitol and get ready to force
entry
they have to go off of inferring [ __ ]
from trump's public statements instead
of getting
a call on a burner phone
from their handler relaying direct
orders
the they have to
go off of a guessing game and then when
things go off plan they don't know
what's happening further up ahead and
that falls apart and
that that uh cutting off of
communications i think is demonstrated
by this by the uncertainty by the having
to interpret from trump's public
statements what their orders are
um that shows that their go-between
was willing to
keep
ties
separate and hidden
to protect themselves from prosecution
if the coup didn't work out on the
paramilitary aspect
even at the expense of undermining the
success of the paramilitary operation
those guys can fall back on the eastman
plan
and if both keepers and proud boys don't
deliver then they just get burned
right right well and and that
um goes back to
like you said this chain of command
being broken um because there really
wasn't one in that trump didn't want a
chain of command because he doesn't want
to be connected to the oath keepers or
the proud boys and the reason why is
because they're white nationalists
they're white nationalists and this
brings me to
this um
gateway pundit uh jailhouse interview
with stuart that was released i don't
know a couple days ago i guess it's been
um yesterday or the day before go ahead
and dredge it up dredge up the childhood
memories let me hear this sweet sultry
voice of my childhood yes so so this is
so this is stewart
talking to
and i'm assuming it's the same gateway
pundit reporter that's been doing these
jailhouse interviews uh and stuart's
kind of been all over the map with these
interviews
uh if you've listened to any of the
audio from the gateway pundit um
interviews that they put out
this one specifically though
he he really he's got something to say
i i find it funny that last week he was
begging the january 6 select committee
to come in and give his side of the
story in front of the lights and the
cameras in the microphone this week he
wants to sue them because he was hanging
out with a bunch of white nationalists
now for people who don't know
january 5th there is a documentary that
was being made
and stuart rhodes appeared in a parking
garage
with enrique tario who was not supposed
to be in washington dc
that day he was
he was barred from being inside the city
by a judge because of a rally that
happened weeks before and he burned
a sign in front of a church
and they weren't going to allow him into
the city on the 6th for
obvious reasons but stuart rhodes my
view is
because there was private conversations
that weren't recorded
my view is
that was a passing of the church because
what we
what we noticed the next day is
someone named roger stone who is
possibly that back channel for the qrf
and the orders from the president of the
united states who knows
or michael flynn would be my two top
rights right because michael flynn we
know has been uh liaison with the proud
boys and the oath keepers both
but it seems like that meeting in the
garage where he's meeting with the white
nationalist group the leader pr proud
boys
um where it's almost like a passing of
the torch like they don't know what's
going on again back to the whole you
know fractured plan fractured chain of
command they have no idea
so they're trying to make the best of
what situation they have without having
direct orders from this back channel
but it seems as if the prowl boys switch
the security from them to the oath
keepers which
um those oath keepers are now pleading
guilty and cooperating who are
protecting roger stone which should make
roger stone and stuart rhodes
very very [ __ ] nervous is the way i
see it that's why i've always believed
that roger stone is probably the
likelihood
that he is one of the back channels and
maybe you know as stewart rhodes might
and the oath keepers and the proud boys
might have had a backup plan where they
had uh roger stone and mike flynn i
don't know i don't know if the
department of justice would be able to
actually
smoke that out or not it seems like the
january 6 select committee has evidence
of a back channel and who it is
um chose not to address it for the time
right
right well and that could be like you
said earlier because the department of
justice doesn't want to ruin a criminal
case against that person or that person
is now cooperating in an effort to move
up the chain
a little fish big fish stuff like we
talked earlier but let's go to go ahead
anything
that sinks
a conviction
of
stuart rhodes in connection with this
back channel and especially anything
that sinks
his connect
is very bad for donald trump
that provides the clearest stepping
stone to prosecuting trump for january
6th and the most solid
if trump goes down and the evidence in
his trial includes
his secret communications with an
intermediary with the white house
that is the silver bullet
so do you think you know speaking of
that and i'm gonna go to the tape here
of the gateway pundit interview where
he's threatening to sue this six
committee um for calling him a white
nationalist appropriately but
but
do you think these gateway pundit
interviews more than anything are
stewart road signaling to donald trump
i think he's signaling to anybody who
will listen he's very much feeling like
he's been let out left out to dry which
you should have expected he knows the
history of how this [ __ ] works he knows
that the brown shirts got purged once
hitler took power you should have seen
it coming you're talking about the essay
yeah
the essay once they outlived their
usefulness the sa and the
weirdo uh weirdo left-wing uh
factions of the nazi party
got purged and executed and imprisoned
in
uh one in a one night shotgun shock and
awe campaign called the light of night
of the long knives stewart has ranted
about that at length
in all throughout my childhoods he
should have seen it coming and he should
have known from trump's personal history
that if he failed to deliver
he would just be blamed for failing
trump
and would be left hanging
and now he's shouting for anybody who
will listen and trying to remain
relevant so let's listen to him
let's listen to the shouting
yeah let's listen to the shouting from
from the
the uh the jailhouse phone let's listen
for your uh members to uh
to press charges if they feel that that
that's something they want to do against
uh
this blast for me though
they can sue him because they can sue
jesus
and also benny thompson has made
statements calling oath keepers a white
supremacist organization or white
nationalist in the media he did that
along with the president of the naacp
unfortunately right and so they're not
just saying inside the halls of congress
is singing out of the media which makes
them vulnerable to being sued so they
should be super defamation for sure so
one thing about
so so um for people who don't know
because we do have an interview with you
and your mom tasha um who
has said in the past that
the
founding tenements of
the oath keepers and stewart tried to
keep white nationalists at one point he
actually would go to an extent to purge
white nationalists that would
even give any kind of hint
of racism white nationalism kkk um you
know on
the social media he would purge them
from the oath keepers
but he walked away from that as trump
came to power and obviously he met with
tario before the sixth um who is the
leader of a white nationalist group who
don't pick bones about it so why do you
why do you think stuart here is do you
think he's just crying into his spilled
milk here
he
really really wants his supporters to
take action that will protect him
from further damaging testimony by the
committee that personally hurts him and
oath keepers
he would very much really wants personal
revenge on tatinho for speaking out
against him is
what i would say
and he's desperately trying to maintain
the separation between oath keepers and
white nationalists that protected both
keepers throughout most of his career
now this is something that i covered
a bit in uh my latest piece of writing
but
uh stuart not only obsessed over
uh whether posters on
like websites like stormfront the
holocaust denial center
and white pride website that
uh from posters who were saying that
they were oath keepers members and
trying to infiltrate he obsessed over it
and he saw white nationals infiltration
of oath keepers as a deadly threat
because it would mean that oath keepers
members
would be stripped of security clearances
for
being in an organization that accepted
uh racists or felons and
would taint them in the eyes of the
media because for a while he was trying
to make oath keepers into a legitimate
organization
on a national scale
or using that whatever legitimacy he had
as cover
and
while this was going on behind the
scenes
he would maintain ties with figures like
chuck baldwin and matt shea who have
deep connections to
the white nationalist christian identity
movement
and
accepted that so there was always a
practical willingness
to be friends of friends with white
nationalists
as long as he kept it on the down low
and in his desperation
to
hide behind trump's skirts and also to
use trump as a ladder towards his own
power and relevance
uh stewart became more willing to accept
ties
with neo-nazis and white nationalists
under the great trump umbrella
and where previously he kicked out
everyone who went to charlottesville
which is brings us back to tattenhofe in
one of his interviews uh tottenham
remains silent while a tv show host
is
uh talking about oath keepers and
charlottesville and
for weeks stuart had been losing it over
charlottesville and was demanding that
nobody goes to charlottesville if any of
you idiots insist on going to
charlottesville you are not bringing
your oath keepers apparel or merchandise
with you or you are banned for life and
some guys did anyway
and got photographed wearing oath
keepers shirts and that is what got oath
keepers kicked off of paypal
and
tattenhove would have been absolutely
still in the loop at this point but the
timeline that he testified to publicly
in previous interviews says that he cut
ties fully
sometime before that so he couldn't
really express an opinion on it on the
entire fiasco and the internal schism
that happened with this purging of
members from the roles over attending or
supporting
charlottesville and damaging the
organization
i think irreparably
as a result
now
that said well i'm not the world's
biggest fan of tattoo and probably never
will be for my own reasons
tatton hove going and giving those
interviews and
especially his work on his colorado
switchblade newsletter where he's been
talking
in very plain terms about
every
uh everything the gop is trying to pull
off right now he's doing good work he's
telling the truth he's getting
an important message out there
so right now he is absolutely working on
the side of good
but
that
bit about charlottesville
is
again just a little bit of
where he could
have taken the opportunity
to
spread a little bit of knowledge about
how the exact interplay between oath
keepers in the charlottesville protest
worked and the decline of both keepers
and shows not to because he's trying to
downplay how long he was still involved
well
and that dating hove may be doing the
same thing that stewart is doing here
where he's saying oath keepers should
sue the slight committee and benny
thompson for calling them uh white
nationalists now here's the thing
because you know you mentioned the gop
as a whole and the direction the gop and
and the actual alarm that tatinho jason
montano set off during that hearing that
he was in and he's still doing with some
of his work
is that
it's not just the oath keepers it's not
just the proud boys it's not these white
nationalist groups they are inside one
political party and we only have a
two-party system here in this country
and he was trying to sound the alarm
because
stewart's
stewart's case
that
that benny thompson calling uh oath
keepers white nationalists is what kind
of like inflammatory harm has been done
that hasn't already been done well but
anybody else is appealing to right now
would be turned off by them calling
being called white nationalists by benny
thompson they would take it as a selling
point well think about it we have we
have marjorie taylor greene and lauren
bobert who who embraces
well they're christian white
nationalists they're even a step further
towards nazis but listen the the the
actual gop is embracing nationalism and
not just nationals but christian white
nationalism and and they're begging
they're begging for anyone to pardon
stewart and the rest of the january 6th
select insurrectionist and if that isn't
white nationalism white christian
national whatever they want to bill it
as and call whatever they want christian
nationalism white national whatever they
want to do what however the hell they
want to you know because they do this a
lot
we talked about this before is they go
with one brandy like oh that was really
horrible at charlottesville because some
guy took a car and tried to murder a
bunch of people and did kill somebody
and he's convicted now so we got to
change our name to patriot front like
and we got to change our outfits now so
we all look similar right like they
got to change up our uniform we got a
rebrand yeah that's right so the
rebranding now is is marjorie taylor
green is not only not only embracing
christian nationalism but she is saying
into a microphone
that hey i'm a proud
she says this i'm a proud christian
nationalist i'm like holy actual [ __ ]
like really you can't get more fascist
than exactly what they're doing and it's
always a
this summer is
victor orban
the
uh great granddaddy of all the
conspiracy theories about his previous
political rival in hungary george soros
uh
one of the architects of the actual vast
right-wing conspiracy new world order
that's been playing
the projecting blame game with all of
its opponents
is going to be speaking at cpac this
year on the heels of a public statement
where he stated and this is the current
head of state of hungary the president
of hungary right stating
pro-putin basically putin's uh pet dog
inside the european union
that uh
nations in which races mix are no longer
really nations and that is why he
opposes hungarians becoming a mismixed
race people and losing hungarianism
that sounds familiar that sounds like
yes
doesn't it and now he's going to be
speaking in the united states at this
summer's cpac
well that's not surprising since cpac
took it to to um hungary to have their
little hungarian style fascist uh nazi
rally there and that's where they uh
just expressed open admiration for how
uh
orban's uh conservative party cemented
minority rule and has affect has banned
their political rivals like george soros
from ever being in the country again
and has essentially rigged it so that
very theoretically they could lose an
election but in all practicality it is
impossible so they are just openly
worshipping the man who game planned
what they plan to do in the united
states we all need to pay attention
and we should keep a close eye on uh
victor orban's little visit to the us
so let let's touch on one more thing
before we go
because we talked about this in private
you bro you brought up the words new
world order and the right wing has
always used this as a fear factor they
they use all kinds of things as fear
factors to get people really riled up
and scared about something to activate
their base and especially violently i
think that's a little bit what donald
trump has been doing in his last rallies
is to
get his
get unsanctioned violence i think as you
called it in one of our interviews um
but tell us tell the audience about
because we talked about the new world
order privately tell us how
you believe in their quest of convincing
the right wing
uh or or the followers of the right wing
that there is a new world order they
have created one and we see that through
orbon we see that through putin and we
see that in these right-wing um you know
these right-wing pockets throughout the
world it's kind of popular political
groups with intertwined funding with
interlinks between political operatives
the uh
the
slander of george soros and
the
birther conspiracy theory about uh
president barack obama were masterminded
by political advisors who had worked for
urban who came over from hungary to work
for the gop
the links are very clearly there and
what we have
is that all accusations that
liberal democrats leftists socialists
neoliberals anybody who likes the united
nations
and the neoliberal global global order
as it exists today the international
order
or nato or anything else they're all
part of a vast sinister conspiracy to
institute
uh totalitarian rule worldwide and take
your rights away
all the people promoting this
are running in the same authoritarian
populist circles using pop right wing
populist rhetoric pulling from the same
sources of dark money
and rubbing shoulders continuously in
their efforts to
overthrow democracies and install
authoritarian governments and what that
is starting to look like a lot
is this proud tradition
dating all the way back to hermann
goring
of always accusing your enemy of that
which you do
i am starting to pure projection i'm
starting to believe
that every accusation of the new world
order
has been a confession the entire time it
becomes clear when you look at the deep
ties between orban and the current gop
becomes clear when you look at vladimir
putin's funding for right-wing terrorist
groups the world over and his ties with
right-wing populist and isolationists in
france and the uk and their meddling and
brexit and the 2016 presidential
election in the united states you even
see russia's involvement with the nra
and tying putin absolutely
very clearly uh sexy russian sex pot
handlers
um
handling in multiple ways uh gop
operatives and nra executives
to keep them on track you know you
always have a way to to uh lightly step
over the sex part you know that you know
that you have the uh you have the
ability to do that i don't have the
ability to do that i just say it she was
she was they they were trying to give
him handies you know that's what i would
say you said handle in certain ways but
i
you know i don't know
i don't know even uh like
russian escorts who work for the kgp
have standards i would expect that was
just an extended game of whack-a-mole
well it could be it could be and i
didn't mean to interrupt you but but i
think you're right in that the
projection of the new world order
because you you know you probably heard
more about this than i did because i
wasn't a part of the militia movement i
mean what's this new world order every
absolutely everything every that's where
it all comes from everything is new
world order and now that i've become
more aware
i'm tracing back all the propaganda and
the tracing back of all this propaganda
keeps ending up in the same places
even early q anon and the early
conspiracy theories about
uh
hillary clinton's email server wrapped
in george soros somehow like he the
origin point of
george soros being the the militia
movement right wing boogie man dates
back to
the gop getting in bed with
hungarian authoritarians the hungarian
authoritarians are deeply up the asses
of putin's russia
it's kind of where the competing brand
that we see is
china's belt and road initiative where
china is supporting
just
with no qualms any authoritarian
government
that will sign a deal with them where
they are theoretically communists but
completely on board with anti-communist
dictatorships that all mutually support
each other across ideological lines
in a self-supporting international
network of
despots
and i think
they're that's a competing brand with
what
this global right-wing movement is
attempting to do throughout the western
world
south america and the middle east
because we've seen
faltering attempts at the gop to court
the taliban
since their takeover of afghanistan
and to bring pro-taliban propaganda into
right white supremacist messaging
it's the attempt to assemble
an international league of super evil
to overthrow liberal democracy once and
for all
and i think the new world order has
always been projection i think the new
world order has always been right-wing
i think i think you're on to something
there and and tell us because i know
you're going to write about this in your
your your new sub stack and some of the
streams you're doing so tell the
audience before we go
exactly where they can find everything
dakota
pump that shilling pump that showing so
yep i am now it and uh you can get taken
by link tree if you just go to
dakotaviadams.com
um you know and you'll find
the link to my weekly one hour
uh weekly wednesday live stream where i
do question answering
and a couple of select youtube videos
and dramatic readings of
right-wing media and especially
right-wing science fiction that i grew
up with
and survivalist training videos and then
also my sub stack
where i
post weekly odd stories from my
childhood that will always forever be
freely available
and
my upcoming series of deprogramming
essays that cover social justice and
political issues
in language that is simple and from an
argument angle that will appeal to your
republican uncle who's a little bit
smart and might be brought around which
is one of my main goals when i started
writing along with that you will get
um
regular hot takes on current events and
reactions to
um right-wing political rag trends
and current malicious shenanigans
so go follow dakota
on his sub stack and go check out his
his twitch stream i was there for the
first and it was fantastic don't forget
anything no no it was great very bad no
good live stream it was a great live
stream so go to
dakotavadams.com our file dakota on
twitter at dakota v adams dakota thanks
for joining us again come back thank you
for having me on from the shed
i have nothing else going on in my life
well we'll talk to you soon my friend
have a have a great have a great one
we'll talk to you too see you next time
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking